what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest
in the dragon ball super story and as
you've probably heard by now
this is one of the most controversial
chapters possibly ever
in dragon ball super so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing the dragon ball super reviews on
this channel then smash that like button
to keep them coming and share this video
with any saiyans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future dragon ball videos
make this the day you subscribe if you
haven't already
and if you are a dragon ball fan feel
free to check out the dragon ball virgin
podcast which i host with my buddy ray
who hasn't watched dragon ball
or anime in general we discuss an arc
every week and started from the
beginning of the dragon ball story and
we're almost at dragon ball z now which
i'm very hyped about
so yeah if you want to relive the
greatness of dragon ball or discover it
for the first time
check out the dragon ball version
podcast link in the top of the
description
or you can just look it up on spotify
apple podcast or wherever else you
listen to podcasts
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all now as you guys
know i am super grateful when we get new
chapters for all these series that i
love
and i tend to focus on the positive
stuff rather than the negative stuff
that's just how i'm wired so i'm not
gonna hate too much on this chapter
although i know a lot of people do hate
it but i will acknowledge the points
that were arguably
very problematic as we go forward so we
got krillin with the senzu beans
and he finds ultra instant goku the
whole ultra instinct goku battle was
absolutely epic last chapter
i loved it and i loved watching goku
completely overpower moro
but then what happens let's find out so
krillin is psyched because it doesn't
look like goku will even need a senzu
bean goku proceeds to straight up turn a
big boulder into sand from a distance
a subtle but nice flex morrow emerges
and goku tells him to stand up now
that's pretty hilarious because goku is
calling the shots completely
and moro has no choice but to listen
goku takes the senzu beans
and then does something that made a lot
of people angry and krillin didn't even
have a chance to be the sensible one
here
because goku took the senzu beans before
krillin even knew what was happening
and i gotta say for the dragon ball
version podcast i've been watching
through early dragon ball
and goku and krillin are best friends
there so i love seeing that after so
many years and chapters these guys are
still so close
and we're still seeing krillin in the
story yeah krillin is not as strong as
goku anymore but i still love seeing him
and the fact that he married best girl
android 18 kind of makes up for the fact
that he's not the strongest
not gonna lie but yeah if goku told him
what he was gonna do with the senzu
beans krillin might have tried to stop
him but goku didn't
goku said he'd spare moro if he agreed
to come to the galactic prison
and promise not to break out again i
don't know how goku could
ever trust such a promise but okay goku
is confident in his skills
and he likes showing mercy to enemies
especially when he thinks they're no
longer a threat
morrow lies through his teeth saying
he's a changed goat man
and then instead of taking him to the
prison goku gives him a senzu bean
was it stupid yeah it was pretty stupid
especially after merus gave up his life
because of how dangerous moro was and
even in dragon ball there are times when
goku is suspicious of enemies and
doesn't trust them
so the fact that he trusts moro after
everything is not
very realistic you could say that he's
confident in his abilities
and that does happen to goku but we only
have to remember when whis
had to turn back time in order to save
the planet from frieza
goku should have learned from that
moment if not others
to not give his opponent a chance to you
know destroy the earth and giving
someone as strong as moro a senzu bean
definitely increases the chances of
earth destruction
but let's keep going i also love how
goku says that joko will escort a fully
healed moro back to prison
like that would ever go smoothly and
even jocko is shocked to hear this
jaco says what we are all thinking even
if goku wasn't gonna kill moro
he at least shouldn't have healed the
goat dude
and of course right after he's healed
the very second after
moro goes back on his promise to go to
prison
i don't think any of us were surprised
by that they say you can't teach an old
dog new tricks
and since morrow is like millions upon
millions of years old
it is unlikely he'll change just like
that then morrow goes to punch goku
and we get an epic moment where goku's
body reacts strengthening itself to the
point where morrow's arm actually breaks
and i was thinking here okay this time
goku may just be so strong and fast that
moro really can't do anything to him
it's still not smart to give him a sense
of beam but at least the power gap seems
pretty unbridgeable
beerus is understandably mad wondering
why goku is messing around instead of
finishing the job
goku calls moro a sneaky coward but
still
he doesn't finish him off instead he
starts telling him to train
since moro never did because morrow
viewed it as a crutch for the week
and at this point it is pretty hilarious
that goku is telling this guy who cost
merus his life
how to get even stronger that part in
goku that loves a good challenge
and a good fight is too strong for his
own good and he thinks about how nice it
would be if morro was a decent guy
because then they could fight together
again joko just like beerus
tells goku to finish him off already he
went against his word after all
we gotta acknowledge that about this
chapter at least it's not like the
mangaka doesn't know what goku is doing
is stupid he has multiple characters
constantly telling him that he's making
a mistake
and to finish it off in this chapter but
goku is just
really really bad at learning his lesson
and following their
advice in dragon ball super we can't
deny that
goku says he will finish him off but he
wants to talk
some more and here we have tak no jutsu
have the complete
opposite effect that it does in naruto
in naruto tak no jutsu can actually work
and stop opponents
but here it just works to help out
beaten opponents and give them time to
come up with a desperate strategy
that could actually work and cause a lot
of problems
morrow has a breakdown just like frieza
did not believing that someone like goku
could take him down and then goku asks
him one more time
if they'll go back to prison quietly and
then it happens
morrow spots one last hope and quickly
comes up with a strategy
he sees the arm that grabbed merus and
plans to reattach it
so he can use betosus power morrow says
he won't go to prison
and goku says that he has no choice but
to kill him because he promised merus to
protect the galaxy
and i like that he is keeping medusa's
sacrifice in mind but goku bro
you should want to protect the galaxy
for you and because it's the right thing
to do
even without the promise made to merus
moro keeps talking and tak no jutsu is
clearly super effective against an
opponent like goku
moro proceeds to reattach his arm and to
use meru's
ultra instinct powers as well now
despite how it happened
this is a pretty crazy twist if it
happened while morrow was still damaged
and the arm was under the boulder with
him and stuff this would have been just
an
intense and interesting turn it's just
the fact that goku gave him a sense of
bean and so much time
that kind of takes away from it but
either way we now have a hype match up
with an ultra instant goku
and an ultra instinct moro who has
access to freaking angel powers
in theory he's pretty much the biggest
threat the z warriors have
ever faced for a while goku and moro
seem pretty evenly matched
their power is so great that they are
destroying the earth with their clashing
punches as morrow points out they are
equally matched but moro also has his
magic
which should put him a step ahead in
goku's defense he continues to be calm
making it look like he has things under
control despite this crazy twist but
angel power
is no joke and a non-angel body trying
to contain it
let alone an untrained one begins to
swell up
morrow starts ballooning like he's about
to explode
so again it seems like goku has him on
the ropes
there's a chance that like with frieza
on namek
moro still can't do any damage to goku
anymore
meaning that his blunder wouldn't be as
big of a blunder
and i do like how moro's body is
rejecting the power
it did feel a bit cheap to me how moro
could just copy any power without
training so i'm glad that he's reached
something that he can't just easily copy
without repercussions
like we're talking about angel power
here so it makes sense that it's too
much
if not moro could just copy zeno's power
and rule everything effortlessly but
moro ever the quick thinker especially
compared to goku
starts looking for a body that could
endure so much power
and finally even whis tells goku dude
stop messing around
and finish him this instant goku says
finally okay
but he takes his time and keeps talking
just for once i'd like for someone to
say
goku finish him off and goku just
immediately releases the finishing blast
but
it's not to be as a famous cowboy once
said when you gotta shoot
shoot don't talk and moro takes
advantage of goku's slowness to combine
with the planet
which is crazy and i didn't see it
coming now morrow says he has no limits
and worse we says that morrow and the
planet share the same fate now
so now to kill the enemy goku has to
destroy the earth he's been protecting
his whole life
and his swollen energy is supposed to
detonate destroying the whole galaxy
so that's merusa's worst nightmare right
there goku is not so calm anymore and
for good reason now this is a very
interesting twist having an opponent
combined with the earth i myself have no
idea how they can stop him now
and want to read on to find out which is
a good thing but yeah it has to be said
that goku should not have let this
happen
and i get it if people are upset by how
many chances goku gave
moro to do this goku was very fazed by
merusa's death
and yet he still allowed what meadows
dreaded most to possibly happen by
showing too much mercy
to a clearly bad dude something that got
him in trouble many times before
and he even had to be bailed out by whis
before
again i'd like for this to be handled
without whis or god intervention but i
must admit i have no idea
what they're going to do here and how
they'll solve this very avoidable
problem
and that is it for this chapter let me
know what you thought of it
are you upset by goku's character did
you appreciate the interesting twists
and turns we got in this one
and seeing more of ultra instant goku
which is always pretty cool
let me know in the comments there's been
a lot of talk about dragon ball
super and if it should be a thing but
for me sequels can't ruin originals
and i will continue to enjoy super as a
sort of bonus for dragon ball fans
and i definitely do prefer getting more
super to getting nothing
and you never know super can have a lot
more highlights that we really enjoy
in the chapters to come but let me know
if you're in the same boat or not
if you do enjoy seeing the dragon ball
super reviews on this channel then smash
that like button to keep them coming
and share this video with any saiyans
that you know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select all or you
will
miss future dragon ball videos make this
the day you subscribe
if you haven't already and if you are a
dragon ball fan
feel free to check out my dragon ball
virgin podcast
which i host with my friend ray who
hasn't watched dragon ball
or anime in general for that matter we
discuss an arc every week and we started
from the beginning of the dragon ball
story
and we're almost all the way up to
dragon ball z now which i'm very hyped
to start
so yeah if you want to relive the
greatness of dragon ball or discover for
the first time with us
check out the dragon ball version
podcast link in the top of the
description
or you can just look it up on spotify
apple podcasts or wherever else you
listen to podcasts
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by
lord twigo himself alpha sigma and liam
thompson
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand on top all clans
in grada the world acquire respect pate
hepa jonathan king rethuan day aura
red haired raven emperor otaku thomas
jones kin mono admirath
and christopher torley and are pro hero
to your patrons the one and only
gilgamesh who's the current most donated
overall champion of the world
nothing but a fan steelers anatoly
kazatsuki cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica calefon
alicia actor
hinokami and water bonnie parks florian
joanne garcia mick sheamus deadly saint
and high school dxd73
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com anime uproar
and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron-only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
animeopro
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you